uh firefighter has been a target of
racism this Friday night I'm Mark Wilson
and I'm Ali Corey thanks for being with
us first tonight at 10 troubling
allegations of racism at a fire station
in Tampa there's no racist people in
Tampa merch moved out
a firefighter says over the past several
there's still like two or three people
left I don't know if any of them are
firefighters though oh okay me neither
he's been the top oh the two or three
people I know they work at Busch Gardens
Target of racially driven harassment
from his fellow firefighters all right
but I want to know what they what did
they do I want to know about the prank
because
it's because he spoke out against this a
monkey he says is hanging by a noose at
the station that monkey is not hanging
by a new surroundings it's Granny but
grabbing it by the hand and dangling
like Donkey Kong this is another
scenario
another bubble Wallace of them of them
doing something not racist and him being
more racist by pointing out that what
I'm a monkey hungry person yeah what are
they just going up to him and being like
hey Dave that's you I don't think that's
you little monkey man I don't think I
don't think the Puerto Rican
firefighters are doing that in Tampa to
be honest with you
Fox 13's Kaylee Tracy is in our Newsroom
tonight in case
Haley these are some serious accusations
here but the accusations are stupid
those you could I bet you I bet you're
going to Amazon right now so let me get
this straight they hung a goofy monkey
like but again by the hand so it looks
like he's just kind of dangling whatever
you came into work
and you saw that and went that's me you
saw your like why are we all responsible
nowadays
for how everyone else reacts to things
and feels about things right like like
gay people Jewish people black people
women they all want everything changed
because of how they feel about something
and it's all this made-up [__] in their
head same thing with trans people
they start this fight with you about
pronouns and they're really a woman and
you're like yeah I don't care bro it's
fine I don't care and and it's like oh I
bet you think I'm a freak weirdo huh I
bet you think I'm a [__] disgusting
frequent and you're like I haven't said
a word to you and it's the same thing
with this same thing when you bring up
you know uh greedy Bankers or something
and a Jewish guy's like hey hey you
don't talk about Soros that's
anti-semitic wait what and you're like
why are you getting guilty about it I
guarantee you nobody said hey you're the
monkey hanging from the thing which that
did I would go okay guys that is so out
of bounds we are definitely gonna have
to pay out a lawsuit
and the firefighter says it gets worse
yeah and how does it get worse Mr Dixon
says yesterday he opened his locker and
found a picture of himself with the word
monkey written across his forehead he's
lying he's lying he did that himself he
did that himself I don't [__] lying I
don't buy it and you know what there's
no [__] proof how do you prove that I
guaran bro if it was if it was does that
betting site that doesn't [__] things
we bet on this can we bet on hate crimes
because I'll tell you right now if that
were the case
then if you're so confident right and
this isn't a juicy smoothie situation
then call the police have the FBI come
out treat this as a hate crime check
that picture see if there's any DNA on
it see if there's any fingerprints on it
compare handwriting samples whatever you
got to do let them handle it or are you
not confident you just want a lawsuit
probably right he wants a lawsuit
guarantee get some money out of the city
of Tampa that's what's Happening Here I
guarantee I didn't have it by the way
somebody probably just saw the flag on
the front when the front page of Rumble
was the pride flag with the fist is the
[__] uh thumbnail today repent gay
like scream repent for your crimes
repent
okay it's a joke it's a joke dude we're
not gay or black so calm down we're not
black so I would assume if that part's
not true then obviously the gay thing
isn't true tell the kids it says history
isn't unique but others are scared to
speak up in the fire department but
Dixon hopes by speaking out it will
address what he sees so I'm to believe
I'm to believe that there is some sort
of a vast
white supremacist conspiracy at the may
I yes the Tampa Fire Department it's so
crazy that's right said it's probably
all Puerto Rican it doesn't make any
sense and black guys probably
once you check out mentally it's time to
come back that's him and I almost
honestly it's anything on your wall
straight uh look I suck at Hanging
pictures and stuff too I get it but man
you're way off that gorilla was hanging
straight to go Dixon says in February he
and the other African-American
firefighter on no just him his shift at
station where's the other guy he doesn't
want to be involved in 13 found this a
monkey hanging by a rope from the
ceiling by his hand
I find it ironic how you know this
monkey that was in the station that was
over in the corner collecting dust you
know so that monkey had already been in
that hold on so this this you're coming
undercutting your own argument a little
equipment on it and everything nobody
cared about it and now out of the blue
we'll be going into black history month
and now there's a hanging monkey
it's this is the news this is a story
just happened yeah you [__] sir
this is crazy this is the gay people
want and why do you still have a 4x3
camera with a new side two of it he says
they reported it to their engine Capital
oh wait this was months ago he's saying
okay that makes what happened Black
History Month yes
technically about Black History Month
but black people they were just probably
seeing the monkey while they were moving
equipment and we're like hey I'll put
that up hey you know it'd be silly
because he got that rope hanging up
there you know it'll be really funny
I'll tie this [__] thing of the
monkey's hand and it looks like he's
[__] dangling out there bro dude
thing right that's literally what it is
hey you know you know what the the
monkey would be it's been getting in the
way the equipment and [__] let's just
[__] hang it'll be real funny and
then it's like uh and then this guy just
came into work one day everybody was
having a nice day and he came in and
went oh I see how it is oh I see hanging
from the noose right is that what we're
doing we're hanging in from the news
nah man everybody's just having a coffee
reading the paper like why are you
acting what are you talking about dude
like that's down it's like it's all in
your [__] head stop he's like my
wife's black bro like what are you doing
to our home
[__] man
you wanted my idea on it I think he was
go ahead into work this morning thinking
God damn it I [__] hate this job and
I hate having to wait are you saying
open the [__] door and seen the
monkey and goes I can sue the [__]
City now thank you are you saying that
he put up the thing himself
I'm saying that's quite the possibility
I wouldn't doubt it four stringers in
the chat Center I'm waiting for the
smoke detector peep
one that was a [__] that was a good
one home run right there at least it was
a double
uh Chuck Norris Gun Club brah two
dollars thank you thank you thank you
we all come from monkeys so you
shouldn't feel that bad Dixon that
didn't happen I'm telling you this guy's
lying I know Liars he's a liar says
Tampa Fire Rescue did an investigation
and interviews he says he was told those
involved said the incident was a way to
honor Busch Gardens the station's
neighbor Dixon says he was told the
investigation has concluded and no other
action was taken so they didn't do
anything because nothing happened
because nothing happened and honestly
again if you were so confident that this
was what they were doing give that
[__] uh give the monkey and give the
[__] uh the little picture from your
locker that supposedly exists that you
totally didn't make yourself and hand it
over to forensic people who again
nowadays in 2023 I don't give a [__]
dude if you even breathe near something
they'll get some DNA off it you know
what and you know what if we find out
that some guy is walking around the
[__] fire station right monkey and
[__] on [__] black people pictures
and putting in a locker yeah I'm all
forgetting that guy [__] fired but
this none of us you know what they ran
this all the way up the [__] ladder
to this racist piece of [__] I just
looked up by the way Tampa Fire Rescue I
looked at the Tampa Fire Rescue I looked
I looked up this white
supremacists I
[__]
no look up look up Tampa Fire Rescue
Chief City of Tampa
what a [__] [__] I I felt it
coming as soon as you were like there's
a wiping oh no
oh
no Mary J Blige is not the fire chief
all the way to this woman and she's like
is he [__] come on seriously
because that's when things escalated
specifically yesterday yeah because you
accuse him of being racist and now
they're pissed [__] and I go to move
my bed so you want to sue
the fire department
you want to deprive Emergency Services
of necessary funding it's not like
you're suing the police department for
shooting you right or a drunk cop on
duty hitting you with his car this is
like you want to take money from
firefighters and EMTs and you want to
potentially get some people who save
lives for a living fired from their jobs
doing a job nobody really wants to do
it's a shitty job it is a shitty job
well no actually
there's that some firefighters that are
just sickos and they're all about that
life and then there's a bunch of people
that are a lot of them are getting
cancer can [__] because of the [__]
fumes as I was reading those articles
like it's really [__] apparently
running into burning buildings isn't
good for your lungs and I see a white
piece of paper that's folded
two times
slide down my bedding so I grabbed a
piece of paper and I opened it he's
telling the story like he's like he
wrote it down like he's reading a script
this guy's lying sure enough there's a
picture of me
with the word monkey
text going across my forehead now the
reason he detects smart move that way
they can't do like a handwriting
comparison thing because if it's taxed
how do you know who it is you did this
you did this and by the way you know how
I know you did this because in the same
way that it's 2023 and you still have a
4x3 camera you probably still look at
look look at the print you're still
printing stuff out this is 100 he did
this himself
text going across my forehead Dixon
thinks in conciliation for speaking
calling rape white supremacists I'd like
to see the other are people in this
exact building I want to know what the
other firefighters look like she's also
just said uh that he thinks this was
retaliation because this happened after
they did the report about the monkey
hanging from the thing yeah so you're
telling me
that after
dodging barely dodging by the Skin of
Their Teeth uh racism allegations almost
losing their jobs right
and then they they win whatever the
[__] investigation you're telling me
these [__] knowing they're now being
watched even more carefully went and
wrote monkey on your locker I don't
believe that because if you just [__]
barely Escape getting in trouble why
would you double down unless you did it
even gotten to this point Tampa Fire
Rescue said in a statement quote Barbara
the black woman Tampa Fire Rescue takes
these allegations he's gonna [__]
he's gonna be [__] watch you're gonna
see him uh in like three weeks he's
gonna be back on the news going like
yeah look at least he's going to be on
[__] rope around his neck with a
Subway sandwich in his hand yeah going
like they attacked me
Police Department to investigate
I was in Emperor City and they said this
is Mega country and they put a noose
around my neck and the Tampa Police
Department says officers are thoroughly
investigating this they say it is an
open and active investigation why would
police officers be investigating this
this isn't a crime
even if there even if it's true
it's not a crime well it would be
technically a hate crime by today's
standards if it was true but even that
it's like what do you can't do I mean
it's stupid
Dixon says he's considering transferring
stations but he hasn't made his mind up
yet so you know so it's obviously not
that bad speaking out because it's
obviously not that bad then right hats
off to him for speaking out this is why
people hate the news this Fox 13 by the
way just to keep keep in mind that if
you're wondering how let me tell you
something Corp [__] uh Fox's
compromise or the Fox News being
compromised piece of [__] local Fox news
has been super compromised for a long
except Houston